heavy snow has brought parts of Europe
to a standstill and there's no sign that
the situation will improve anytime soon
more than 20 people have now died in
what is some of the heaviest snowfall in
two decades and forecasts say more snow
is on its way
DWS army and ISA fizz in one of the
worst affected areas in Austria where
the biggest fear now is avalanches a
silence has fallen over the north side
of Altaussee
this part of the village lies in the
path of an avalanche that authorities
see could trigger without warning over
100 people have been forced to evacuate
a few come back no and then to clear
their roofs or driveways in a constant
battle with the snow it has been snowing
now here for nearly two weeks the
residents tell us they haven't seen
anything like it in over a decade
there's a break in the weather now the
Sun is out but even if the Sun shines
that does not mean the danger of
avalanches is gone the snow has
accumulated it's sitting there and it
could fall off the mountain on to these
houses at any time brakes and the
snowfall have been only temporary here
and Laura Alto say the residents are
getting on with their lives even if that
means hard work
I'm used to a lot of snow but it's a bit
rough this time because we've had so
much at once so far my comm we're trying
to clear just the top layer the loose
stuff if it rains into this then it will
become really heavy the village is
normally packed with tourists at this
time of the year instead luxury hotels
like this one have opened their doors to
evacuate free of charge
Altaf say has pulled together before in
2006 they had to evacuate for a few days
it's that community spirit that locals
say will help them through again
avalanche or not and covering this story
for us these DWS onion ISA if he's in
the Austrian town of Altos a good to see
you tell us how are people coping where
you are well most of the people we
talked to are pretty proud of their
spirit here proud of their ability to
deal with snow they say they've dealt
with it before but they also say that
they've never seen anything like this in
their in their lifetimes some have
likened it to 2006 when there was a
snowstorm but it just wasn't this bad
people are working around the clock like
I said they they have the equipment they
they need to get through this but for
some it's become a part-time job just to
clear the snow we met some guys
yesterday who are up on a roof we asked
him how long they've been up there they
said well it takes it took them two days
to get just half of the roof cleared
working two like two people up there so
it's really a full-time job for a lot of
people but of course the biggest fear
here is an avalanche now in this part
that I'm standing right now there is no
avalanche
there is no avalanche warning it's just
for the people that are in this kind of
narrow valley that sits under a bucket
of snow on the mountain and you can hear
helicopters trying to get rid of
avalanches too they can detonate an
explosion and trigger an avalanche but
they can't do it here because their
houses under there and those people have
had to evacuate right so clearly a sense
of resilience where you are there I mean
what are you hearing from
other snowed-in towns in the region we
talked to the Austrian military and they
are very hopeful about where this is
going they're very optimistic about
their ability to free all of the the
villages that have been snowed in
earlier this week there was about 2200
people in villages that were completely
snowed in that means no access to the
outside world just living off the
resources and you can see the the the
fire patrol is also helping out here not
just the military everybody's pitching
in
but yeah so in the the mountains there
is now only 1500 people stuck they
cleared a path to a village that had
quite a few people in there yesterday
that was a big success of the week right
and not to quash that sense of optimism
and hope there from authorities about
their job they're doing but of course
this situation isn't over yet we know
that more snow is forecast so how are
people preparing for that that's right
there's just snow snow snow in the
forecast if you check your phone you
look at the weather it's snow all week
nobody knows when this is going to let
up actually the we just heard this
morning that the snow up on the mountain
is five meters deep and they won't be
able to measure it soon because the the
measuring center will be completely
buried in so that gives you an idea of
what where this is going
the thing is that even if the weather
lets up even if the Sun comes out even
if it rains that does not reduce the
risk of roofs caving in or avalanches
because water is heavier than snow it
will sit on a roof and we'll create a
severe dangerous situation and of course
for avalanches the problem is is that
snow which weighs tons and tons and tons
and comes down like a train it's just
sitting there waiting to go and Sun and
rain can trigger that all right so
potentially immeasurable amounts of snow
where you are there in the Austrian town
of a Lata's a Onion ISA v' are reported
there thank you very much indeed thank
you